Fire And Blood will reign again and you can
expect to see the Blackfyre Rebellions in
the later seasons of House of the Dragon!
The upcoming Game of Thrones prequel series,
House of the Dragon, is based on the George
RR Martin's Targaryen history book Fire & Blood.
House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
In other words it covers events from Aegon's
Conquest to the Dance of the Dragons.
That's Fire And Blood volume 1.
House of the Dragon will start with a build
up towards the Dance of the Dragons
and early seasons will cover the Dance itself.
Later seasons however,
will be based on George RR Martin’s yet
unfinished Fire And Blood volume 2 book .
The yet unreleased Fire And Blood volume 2
will continue from where part 1 ended, with
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's reign
and will cover Blackyre rebellions, war with
Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King and
Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
How do I know the second part of the Targaryen
history will cover all of that?
Because George RR Martin himself revealed
it.
Fire And Blood volume 1 has 700 pages.
In comparison, the book material Game of Thrones
show used
was 4000 pages with the additional summary
from George RR Martin about the ending.
This prequel will last at least as long as
Game of Thrones and to achieve that,
the showrunners will use Fire And Blood volume
2 material and as I already said,
the main events of it are the Blackfyre Rebellions
and the Robert's Rebellion
so this is something you will see on screen
in the later seasons of House of the Dragon.
The First Blackfyre Rebellion, originally
called the Blackfyre Rebellion,
was a war fought between the loyalist forces
of King Daeron II Targaryen
and the rebel forces of his half-brother,
Daemon I Blackfyre.
Daemon I Blackfyre, born Daemon Waters, was
a bastard son of King Aegon IV Targaryen
and Princess Daena Targaryen. Legitimized
by his father upon the latter's death,
Daemon took the name "Blackfyre" for himself,
after the ancestral Valyrian steel sword of
House Targaryen, which his father also bequeathed
to him.
Despite his bastard status, Daemon believed
himself the rightful heir to the Iron Throne,
as his father's firstborn (and favorite) child
and ignited a bloody civil war that divided
the Seven Kingdoms against his half-brother
Daeron II Targaryen. But let's get a bit back
to see how it all started.
After King Baelor I Targaryen made peace with
Dorne, he returned to King's Landing
and annulled his marriage to his eldest sister,
Daena.
He then locked Daena so she could not tempt
the lusts of men.
However, Daena escaped her imprisonment on
several occasions,
and towards the end of her brother's reign
became pregnant by her cousin, Prince Aegon.
In late 170 AC, she gave birth to a bastard
son whom she named Daemon Waters.
Baelor I, in response to Daemon's birth, began
a forty-day fast,
which eventually caused his death in 171 AC.
King Aegon IV Targaryen, ascended the Iron
Throne in 172 AC.
In addition to his unacknowledged bastard
son by Daena,
King Aegon IV Targaryen had by his marriage
to his sister, Naerys,
a trueborn son named Daeoron, born in 153
AC, and a daughter, Daenerys, born in 172
AC.
Aegon often clashed with Prince Daeron during
his reign, with Daeron opposing the ideas
and the corrupt style of rule of his father.
Aegon, on the other hand, despised his sister-wife,
Naerys, and his younger brother, Prince Aemon
the Dragonknight, to both of whom Prince Daeron
was close.
Around the same time, rumors began to circulate,
instigated by King Aegon himself,
that Daeron was a bastard born of adultery
between his siblings, Naerys and Aemon.
For the first time, although not the last,
Aegon threatened to name one of his bastard
sons as his heir over Daeron. The rumors about
Daeron's parentage forever remained, but despite
Aegon's threats and japes, Daeron was never
formally disowned.
Meanwhile, two factions began to form at court,
one supporting the corrupt reign of Aegon
IV, the other supporting Daeron.
In 182 AC, Aegon knighted his bastard son,
Daemon Waters,
after the boy won a squire's tourney at the
age of twelve. Aegon publicly bestowed Blackfyre,
one of the Valyrian steel swords of House
Targaryen, on Daemon as well, finally acknowledging
him. There were some who felt that the sword
symbolized the monarchy
as it had been the sword of King Aegon I Targaryen,
the Conqueror,
and had been passed on from king to king ever
since.
Aegon's public gift of the sword eventually
started the talk that Daemon should be king.
Following the acquisition of the sword, Daemon
took the name "Blackfyre" for himself.
In early 184 AC, King Aegon IV Targaryen legitimized
all of his bastards on his deathbed.
Prince Daeron ascended the throne as King
Daeron II Targaryen,
and did all he could to keep the nobly-born
Great Bastards close.
While Daeron had chosen to be crowned with
his father's crown, rumors about his legitimacy
remained.
Daeron was not a warrior, and while Prince
Baelor, Daeron's eldest son by his Dornish
wife,
was all that could be desired in a warrior,
Baelor had the looks of a Martell,
and not, like Daemon Blackfyre, of a Targaryen.
Nobles and knights from the Dornish Marches
began to mistrust both Daeron and Baelor.
These same people looked at Daemon Blackfyre,
the bastard son of King Aegon IV Targaryen
and his cousin, Princess Daena Targaryen,
and saw in him a warrior, grown tall and powerful,
with the hallmarks of Old Valyria (deep purple
eyes, silver-gold hair down to his shoulders),
who was described as having had an "almost
inhumane beauty", being "half a god among
mortal men".
Daemon had come to resemble Aegon the Conqueror
in appearance according to his supporters.
His armor was ornate and costly, all black
and red plate,
and his war helm was distinctive, with batlike
steel "dragon wings" on the sides.
Daemon matured into a man of considerable
charm and strength, mastering all weapons
of the battlefield, but with the sword Blackfyre
in hand he was said to fight like the Warrior
himself.
He won friends easily and women were drawn
to him.
Married to Rohanne of Tyrosh in 184 AC, his
twin sons Aegon and Aemon were born later
that same year. Six other sons, and at least
two daughters followed during the years to
come.
Daemon's supporters claimed that Daemon had
desired his half-sister, Princess Daenerys,
and the singers claim that she loved him as
well. It is said that Aegon, who had seen
more profit in the match with Tyrosh, had
promised Daemon that he could have more than
one bride.
Daeron, however did not agree. The Dornish
concessions and influence,
the sudden change of Dornish enemies to Dornish
allies, Daeron's rumored illegitimacy,
and Aegon IV's public gift of the sword of
kings to Daemon, all were part the seeds from
which the first Blackfyre Rebellion grew.
Still, it took many years for the actual rebellion
to begin.
There was no final insult that resulted in
declaration of Daemon's claim.
Additionally, he had councilors who urged
him to rebel,
and many famous warriors who disagreed with
the peace with Dorne sought him out.
The First Blackfyre Rebellion finally broke
out in 196 AC.
It lasted almost one year and divided the
Seven Kingdoms. Daemon's decision to claim
the throne had been made rashly, and word
soon reached Daeron's court that Daemon meant
to declare within a month. It has been suggested
by Archmaester Merion that Brynden Rivers,
another one of Aegon IV's bastard sons, (who
later went on to become the Three Eyed Raven
and who we met 100 years later in Game of
Thrones) was involved in the news reaching
Daeron.
The Kingsguard was sent to arrest Daemon,
but, with the aid of the master-at-arms of
the Red Keep, Daemon managed to escape imprisonment.
Daemon reversed the colors of House Targaryen,
taking for his own sigil a black dragon on
a red field, which led to his nickname,
the "black dragon" (with Daeron becoming known
as the "red dragon"),
and began to mint his own coinage.
Over the course of the war, battles were fought
between the rebels and loyalists in amongst
other places, the Vale, the westerlands, the
riverlands and the Reach. Half the realm declared
for Daemon.
Ser Quentyn Ball attacked the westerlands,
killing Lord Lefford at the gates of Lannisport
and then defeating Lord Damon Lannister in
turn.
Lord Leo Tyrell participated in the First
Blackfyre Rebellion as well, fighting on behalf
of House Targaryen. He won notable victories
in the Reach against Daemon Blackfyre's supporters.
A key general, Fireball was slain on the eve
of the battle of the Redgrass Field by a common
archer.
The final conflict of the First Blackfyre
Rebellion was the Battle of the Redgrass Field,
in late 196 AC.
Lord Leo Tyrell's forces could not gather
quickly enough to arrive in time for the battle.
House Arryn did participate, as Lord Donnel
Arryn led the vanguard of the Targaryen forces.
However, Daemon Blackfyre shattered his lines,
leaving the loyalists in peril until Ser Gwayne
Corbray of the Kingsguard arrived with reinforcements.
Ser Gwayne Corbray and Daemon Blackfyre came
face-to-face during the battle.
Their epic duel, in which Daemon wielded the
Valyrian steel sword Blackfyre
and Gwayne the Valyrian steel sword Lady Forlorn,
is said to have lasted nearly an hour
before Daemon gained the upper hand. Corbray
was wounded, but Daemon dismounted,
preventing Corbray from being trampled, and
commanded that he was taken off the field.
While Daemon was doing this honorable deed,
his half-brother Brynden Rivers with his archers,
the Raven's Teeth, had captured and assumed
a position atop the Weeping Ridge,
which overlooked the battlefield and allowed
them to rain arrows down among Daemon and
his commanders. Daemon’s heir Aegon died
first, followed by Daemon himself.
When Daemon’s second son, Aegon’s twin
brother Aemon took up Blackfyre, he was slain
as well.
With Daemon dead, the rebels began to rout.
Aegor Rivers claimed Blackfyre and rallied
the rebels
by leading a charge against the Raven's Teeth,
but was eventually forced to flee
when Prince Baelor arrived with a host of
Dornish spearmen and stormlanders,
while his younger brother, Prince Maekar,
rallied what remained of the van.
As such, Baelor crushed the rebel army against
Maekar’s shield wall,
the move later called “the hammer and the
anvil”.
Ten thousand men died, and many more were
maimed and wounded.
The First Blackfyre Rebellion left its mark
upon Westeros for years to come.
Asking a man whether he had fought for the
black dragon or the red was considered a dangerous
question. Aegor Rivers was able to recover
the sword Blackfyre from the battlefield and
escaped to the Free Cities, together with
Daemon's widow and remaining children, eventually
ending up in Tyrosh.
In exile, Daemon's descendants continued their
struggle for the Iron Throne,
resulting in four more rebellions (Second,
Third and Fourth Blackfyre Rebellion, and
the War of the Ninepenny Kings). These attempts
led to the arrest of Daemon's second son (Daemon),
and the deaths of his third and fifth son
(Haegon and Aenys), as well as the death of
a grandson,
also named Daemon. Daemon's last male descendant,
Maelys, was slain during the War of the Ninepenny
Kings by Ser Barristan Selmy, ending the Blackfyre
threat.
That's the story of the Blackfyre Rebellion.
Thank you so much for watching, I hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did please give
it a big thumbs up and I hope to see you in
the next one. Peace!